give us some examples about characters
that people wouldn't resonate with
female characters that girls
particularly wouldn't resonate with and
why
I think Sylvie is a good example but
maybe I can think of
um you know what actually She-Hulk is
probably the best example of it
um because so much of She-Hulk talks
about
um
you know okay she she gets someone
else's power she gets her cousin's power
and her friend asks her
are you gonna is that mean does that
mean you're gonna be part of the
Avengers and what does she say she says
no it's for narcissists and so
immediately there's there's an immediate
cut down of one of the most successful
stories that this universe has told
right about a group of people that that
come together despite their you know
varying power levels and personalities
and they overcome a major super villain
Thanos and immediately it's like no
they're all a bunch of narcissists so I
think she calls them adult orphans and
narcissists and it it right off the bat
says you know sets that tone that if a
group of people choose to live not for
let's say their own day-to-day Glory but
to come together and do something that's
dangerous and that's risky that might
mean that they'll lose their lives and
some of them do lose their lives and
still they're willing to put their necks
out on the line to do the right thing
that's somehow narcissistic but then the
whole show that follows is entirely
revolved around her dating life her a
wardrobe for some reason her career
which is you know that's fine but the
whole thing is about her and that's okay
I think on a personal level that's fine
but how is that not a narcissistic
Endeavor in itself right I think people
often now will start to look at it as
like oh if you want to put an outfit on
and fight for the little guy or you're
just doing that for yourself you're
you're a narcissist right you just want
the glory you want the brand name out
there but if it's female motivated it's
like if she wants to put herself out
there and she wants to do
um she wants to fight for the little guy
in the courtroom instead of out on a
battlefield then that's okay her
motivations are not not to be questioned
uh and I think it's there's that like
subtle difference that I think makes for
people makes makes her a bad
representation out in the world for
little girls to to look at someone else
who's putting out putting themselves out
there as narcissists but my motivations
are never to be questioned because I'm a
female I think that's a very bad lesson
to teach anybody
um that's interesting I think that
you can see this
catty
antagonistic sort of just
Petty behavior that comes through it
seems it portrays women in kind of the
most
juvenile way all of the things that for
quite a long time I think women have
been trying to dispense with this sort
of you don't know me there's this line
from She-Hulk where she's saying um that
I deal with anger on a daily basis when
men tell me about my area of expertise
and when guys look at me on the street
and when blah blah blah like you don't
know anything about anger as she points
at Bruce Banner someone that apparently
the law suggests his uh Hulk Persona is
his abused child battling with his real
adult self like you're going to say
you're genuinely going to sit there and
tell the guy that was abused as a child
that the fact that men can't call you on
the street is somehow comparable but no
because you're a man because you're
coming from a place of patriarchal
oppressive super uh how would you say
like
Advantage privilege
you you don't get to you don't get to
make a comment about this and I mean
let's just talk about the fact that
in She-Hulk when she transforms into the
She-Hulk she's able to still speak and
pick guys up and take them to bed and
stuff yeah I mean Bruce Banner destroys
cities
yeah she
presumably annihilates guy's hips yeah
oh oh my God yes I didn't even think
about that but yes I'll try not to think
about that during the next episode but
uh yeah I think immediately she has you
know control over her emotions
immediately uh she can speak like you
mentioned and the fact that she compares
herself to what Bruce endured right
um but this is another way that they're
really driving home that point that men
are you know so clearly uh you know
worse worse than women in in so many
different ways that it took Bruce I
think something like 15 years to come
you know uh come and really I would say
integrate with his shadow right best way
to put it
um and and the fact that the story says
that he saw his mother get I think get
murdered by his father and that's why he
has all this rage pent up and here he is
offering his wisdom his expertise but
it's it's so funny it's like her very
argument that if someone
that I have to control my anger as a
woman when men in my level of expertise
come and tell me what what to do and
here she is putting down a man that has
been the Hulk for so many years and
dealt with it for so many years and he
has his expertise and there's no room
for her to even consider that he might
teach her something irony you know
completely lost yes but that's the whole
point what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]